[Music]
foreign so then it is time for the Press
preview as always it's our first look at
the front pages and tonight having a
look at the headlines Guardian Economist
say Williams and the former conservative
special advisor Salma Shaw they'll both
be with us from now until just before
midnight good evening to both of you
we'll chat in a second after we've had a
look at those front pages for you why
don't we start with the express leading
with a long-awaited conviction for the
murder of seven-year-old Nikki Allen
whose family blamed police for her
killer remaining at large for 31 years
the eye reports that the former Home
Secretary PRI Patel has accused Rishi
sunak of overseeing what she called the
managed decline of the conservative
party
according to the Guardian Security
starmer is expected to give a speech
tomorrow and which will insist that if
elected labor must introduce reforms
that go further and deeper than those
brought in by Tony Blair in 1997.
the times hears from the businessman Sir
James Dyson who believes the
government's focus on investment in
science and technology is political
posturing while the Ft has news of
diplomatic tensions with the U.S
government accusing their South African
counterparts of funneling arms to the
Russians
is tomorrow's Telegraph saying India is
planning to insist that Britain should
return Treasures it plundered during the
colonial era including the controversial
Kohinoor Diamond which is one of the
crown jewels the paper shows those
jewels on its front page as the king
poses with his son and Grandson the
newly released picture the male brings
attention to its campaign to allow
tax-free shopping for overseas tourists
in the UK while the mirac carries claims
about TV presenter Philip schofield's
future on this morning Phil fights for
job the headline the sun suggests that
one issue at the center of it all is
around with his fellow presenter Holly
Willoughby
and I won't read the headline but
according to the star the pope has some
thoughts about the intimate habits of
Italians goodness and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you can see on
screen during the program you can check
out those front pages uh while you watch
us discussing them and to do exactly
that Zoe Williams and Salma Shah great
to have you with us this Friday evening
uh Salma why don't you kick things off
for us looking at the front of the eye
the former Home Secretary attacking the
current prime minister
yes and uh in normal times I think that
would make uh quite a big splash as it
has with the eye but I would treat this
with a bit of skepticism so the former
Home Secretary of pretty Patel has come
out and said that Rishi sunak are the
consequence of the local elections the
dial local election results of the
conservatives is managing the decline of
the party and it's not a surprise
because pretty Patel was a strong
staunch Ally of the former prime
minister Boris Johnson and uh in the
it's for a while it's been in the
pipeline that there is going to be some
kind of attack from the Boris Johnson
loyalist against vicious sunak and it
was going to be around the time of the
local elections so this is very much
part of that but I think a lot of people
from the Boris Johnson supported group
are going to Rally around uh this line
um in an attempt to potentially uh bring
back that former prime minister and just
quickly before we go to Zoe's how much
of a threat are they do you think
look I think the I think the issue is
this is this is all in the prism of a
new organization called the conservative
Democratic organization which claims to
be a Grassroots
um organization that is speaking on
behalf of the membership it is not yet
clear whether there is any critical mass
of support there but certainly you know
it's getting Traction in the media as we
can see it's on the front pages and
there's a there's a lot of coverage of
it
um but it's seriousness remains to be
seen because there's going to be a lot
that comes out of number 10 and
conservative headquarters to try and
calm down the nervousness that has
occurred as a consequence of these bad
local election results meanwhile uh Zoe
the last line on the front of the eye
says starmer says labor are real
conservatives and pledges to protect our
way of life
I mean
detail on storm are in the guardian
front page which in which he says that
that he's going to be like Blair on
steroids and specifically in that
reference he mentions Clause 4 which is
which was of course Blair's taking on
the left of the party so his explicit
signaling
including that we're the conservatives
now is we're gonna we're gonna do away
with the left of the party once and for
all but within the within what he said
he's talking about the kind of root and
Branch reforms and he mentions that
urgent demands of 65 the Urgent demands
of 45. the the he mentions reforming
labor governments that really pre-date
Blair and it strikes me that he's trying
to do something slightly different to
what he's been doing up until now take
and basically touch you know sing every
song in the Canon so he's not just
trying to do a Blair reboot he's trying
to do it at Lee reboot he's trying to do
a McMillan reboot he's trying he's
trying to kind of every single thing
that anybody who's ever voted labor
likes about the party he's trying to
make that promise now I think it's I
think it's probably not as newsworthy as
he thinks it is because obviously every
labor leader wants to be like the labor
leaders that got elected but I think
it's definitely a kind of direct change
of direction away from the past two
years which have been all about trying
to remodel to a kind of Centrist Blair
right philosophy and close down the left
uh when you mention the front of the
Guardian so let's bring that in next
shall we
um because the headline uh as you say
expect Blair star reforms on steroids uh
says kyostarma um somewhere you know is
this the right direction to go in do you
think
is it the right direction well that
remains to be seen at a general election
but what is the logic behind this the
logic is that labor in 2019 lost it an
enormous amount of ground in its
heartlands to the conservatives under
you know this brexit issue and Boris
Johnson
um and so there is that attempt to
recalibrate to kind of as Zoe says move
away from the corbynias of the left of
the party the difficulty I think for
Sharma as though he's outlined is that
you know it's it's an all a hodgepodge
of like all successful uh labor leaders
so he says he wants a clause for a
moment on steroids but what is the
clause for moment what is he actually
going to want to change and I think
until he sort of makes that clearer and
and what that change is then going to
bring in in terms of a cultural shift
it's just sort of words so I don't
actually know what he's what he's
getting at so Clause 4 is very symbolic
of the blur era until until you put some
detail on it I don't think it is a thing
yeah and also Zoe the the guardian does
make the point that um you know many uh
in the party especially to the left are
going to be frustrated by the u-turns
that we've seen uh Kia Starman may come
or whether it's on tuition fees or
nationalization and that that is an
understandable concern isn't it
well the left of the party have been
incredibly frustrated for a really long
time right and it's not that they're not
just throwing their toys out of the pram
Kip got the became leader on 10 pledges
which were very like John McDonald's
economic program and ever since he got
in he's been trying to disavow anything
that remotely resembles
um John McDonnell and of course his line
would be I've got to distance myself
from the corbyn years and McDonald was
his shadow Chancellor but the the truth
is that it there has been a kind of very
sustained disavowable and repudiation of
the left of his party for a really long
time so I think even though obviously
tuition fees will be a blow to those who
weren't paying attention most people on
that wing of the party sort of know that
he's he's kind of not team
the Corbin or corbyn's successor
um I
I don't know the no there is a as
straightforward as that anymore because
we're kind of in interesting things
happening as well there he's sort of
letting his front bench speak out a
little bit more whereas previously the
message discipline was so intense that
you very rarely heard what anybody
except kirst armor thought
um he seems to be
um it you know as we've seen kind of
touching a lot of a lot of kind of
values points about Labor which aren't
Blair and Blair is a very divisive
figure in the party so there is a lot of
sense in going to kind of previous
leaders and different models and
different models of Victory and
different models of Reform
um yeah for sure it's not going to
amount to hell of being so the manifesto
comes out okay
um and it's a similar theme in the times
let's sort of see what angle they've
taken Salma and they're talking about
the shallow Chancellor setting her
sights on a decade in power and also uh
zooming in on the the whole private
schools issue and charitable status to
our status status which of course makes
big headlines doesn't it for labor but
in the general scheme of things it's not
it's not really going to save the
economy
no but I think this is part of that I
mean this is a terrible phrase but that
sort of hygienic cleansing of a
political party and if I can reference
my own experience you know in the run-up
to the 2010 election there was all this
talk of decontaminating the conservative
brand and we were always accused of not
having enough sort of flesh on the bones
of our policy and like what it strikes
me here is that there is a similar
process going on so it's not sort of big
chunky policies that are being announced
here there's a sort of tonal shift in a
directional shift that the labor party
is taking because you know as the local
elections showed
um there is still a little bit of
nervousness about this new entity under
care starmer and what it actually means
and Rachel Reeves also talking about
this decade of being in power I think
you know to some people that might sound
like it's a foregone conclusion and
Labor's taking it slightly for granted
but I think the intention is to say look
we have a plan and we want to deliver it
and it's for the long term so this is I
think really about about a tonal shift
as opposed to kind of laying any
groundwork for any kind of serious
interventions that are really going to
get the voters talking uh talking of
which
um sorry sorry Zoe jump in
well I was just going to jump in on
Rachel because I think she actually used
the the shadow Cabinet member who's made
the most serious interventions you know
she sketched out the green New Deal plan
which is 128 billion pounds of public
spending of State intervention
um in in a green economy and it is it is
quite extraordinary it's an
extraordinary pledge and it's quite it's
bottomed out you know it's it's very
well thought through it it's costed it's
it's it's it's real
um and I and I suppose that what I'm
pleased about in both that story and
there's and the story which we're just
about to talk about with Angela Rayner's
plans is that those figures are now
saying their piece and labor governments
are much much more successful when
they're a kind of when there's more than
one
um recognizable figure whose kind of
personality whose political personality
voters can recognize okay well let's
just talk about that story you mentioned
we've only got 30 seconds um Salma you
can put outline it for us
um I don't know how this is going to
work for journalists but bosses will be
restricted from contacting their staff
by phone WhatsApp or email outside of
working hours under a labor government
according to plans expected to be in the
party's general election Manifesto
yes this is something that has been uh
looked at and trialled in France as a
consequence of a high profile case and
what this actually means is that people
are allowed to have down time uh and you
know in this Modern Age where we've got
technology when our phones are pinging
all the time this idea that you're never
off uh and so that there is a sort of
considered time that bosses can actually
deal with their employees and I think
for a lot of professions that's going to
be difficult but you know that it is
true people are suffering from burnout
so um I think it could prove to be quite
popular perhaps not in the business
Community but certainly with a lot of
Voters